はぁんっ
どっ
いやわかんないっすよ
ちょっとでげすからどうぞ
パダ
そう
ドアが閉まっている
ここは出口じゃないか
と23 andme
これはモーデックス探してみろお願いしまーす
the braver よ
恋愛の目立ちそうするさ
として俺たちそのじっ込められている
おおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおん
ん
はぁ
voodoo
スプーン
car
ん
玖珠ああ床は誰やーお客さんどうしますからガチで閉じ込められてますこれ
演じたサマンサしかないしたんだ室ゲームなんで多分どこかに影になるものがあると
思うんですよピントを見つけて脱出するんだと思います鳥さんどうします
らぁぁ
さぁづん俺ちょっと素材がよくわからないん
うーんこれは大吾
千鶴しかないのかしかし
何にはでかすぎる何かもう空頂上化けする
あという説だ来てください土井3個
えっおっ100いいんじゃないですかこんな風にそのから
素敵なブロガーを奪った
あつ戻りコービーさん
レっぽくなってきましたねーバクマン
ていましたん
おおーー
[音楽]
かなり削る速度早まるんじゃない
俺を削るぞオレはー
スン
ふぁいだまずちょっと穴でみましょうこの中にヒントが隠されている音声があるなぁ
スタイル
経営ですが入場してきましょう
me
どういうのもあるん
解放されですねまじかえい航されたですか
まず海風さんまじか行こう
ああああああ
本当になバズでだ
ね前にえっなんだぶー
お方ジョジョさぬみたいなぁ
いやーぬなぁ
こっちを弱めているものはてがすごいな姿勢で複雑なんがぁ
me
すーっ
2どうコレだけどですね
銅製
こういうのはよ前
まずだ
まあ作ったなか密着ちょって慣れてるんですかね
[音楽]
全体攻撃していけばピンポジは出過ぎじゃないかどうやって
大変にありがとうござい
おおおおああああ
うわあああ
ん
そうちょっと剤だ
もっと入ってず0
もう
r 2
動いするこんなでゲストは2なかなか手にんですよ
飲酒さあこれ乗員の
ん
対応は言え
某ウェイ
ああああああああ
00分
結構出てきましたねでもあぁ
土井さん
靴溝井付4あああああああああああ
eer
衛兵
レッドできるん
幸い
ええええええ
あっているんです
おーい何ああ
par ん
も sake
けっこうなアレ
太平洋4
同42や照れちゃうぞ
a
右上から読み込みが遅いん
はいはーはっはっは
me
ale
[音楽]
ja
はい村は労力を使わなかった言うんです
どうぞ
はいというわけでさっき釣りましたか削りました
でも2時間でしたガーッというわけで
まじかパーティーという商品が出たんですけどもどんなカードパパと言いますと今まで
にない
エズルカードなんですよ削る早速上げてみましょうかハイね
なにがでるかっていうの楽しい二間塚しまー
覚醒
みてください宿カリームと点灯ベストはこの
帰ってない飾るですけどもこれ
削っちゃっていっ
ずれる早速ちょっと街が気を使って削っていこうと思いますまじ鍵屋
はいこのず何もない奴削ったらこの岩作リームやペットの子みたいに魔神が出てくるん
ですよ
できますよ恋のブーフポッポと
わーっ
はにがとピッツァそっくりえーまた夜王
これは名前はま日系ですねられてみますよ
はいオーレアでバーであれだいいんじゃない
そう夏間近パーティー今までになくてこのパッと開けた瞬間まだわからないです夜明け
で削ってから交通さがわかったりあ
決定は楽しいしと言ってもとますそれがまずかパーに卓球まで何もいなかったカードで
いい
魂が宿りますね
お客さんはどんどん金山てるんですかじゃあ俺はバールニア
ばルニアはパール前とでこの組み合わせて版にあったことになる
この後でとビック3と対戦するんでそう
なるべきついカードが欲しい
のって
もうすでに光ってるんですよこれまでへ
まず浮かんん
削ることによりねっ
you were ちょまて俺が得られそれがは ur
本当ですか僕な
ヨンハて治ってるのはなんだなんだなんだます
ちょっと待ってこれウ
丸山言われましたです
上に削ることにより大
待てよ御坂何かせないそれ金曜になっての音色違いの
なるにはああ
バルにアスカん名前のも行けばいいよ
います
バルーンやじゃない気がするフ
もう誰いや順番や手加減腹にあなぁ
後ろネスト駅西が高く飛んでもなければ家買うメーカー金色なみたいですごいぞこれ
うらやますぃはそんなことあるんだ
いいなピカ配る
まじかー
いやだーーーー
持った
これまずが削るときにマジ回放送って言いながら削るです
そう
ジャン杯目陰謀カード
確定ネットじゃないですか00:00
ずれてますこの人ずしてますとしてますまじかい4
ピタで待ってピタフェニックスで大4位
南部ツールまず上にバーン明けてからてますそれ
それ
からどのカメラ持って言うことに
一枚ですよね
はっはっはっ機と開きましていますきました
虹色のなるネタじゃないんだ次回4
貼っ光っている
いきましたねーなにこれはー無限ブナ
なんか光ってます思うメッツ叱ってません俺は
a 待って最初俺が出したバニーすけど
マッサーカーキラキラしてるバージョンじゃあ回りすけ
ウールドラ o
はい
わー
失せろやバーでパウパウダーってかじゃねええええ
これやばいこのきましたバーン vardia です
だってもうれるぎーみますよ
ウルトラレア
配給釣りを得ましたバーンばルニアです
さあトミカたくさん間近でましたねーネタねぇ
早速手に入れたまじかを使って早速まずがバトルしてみましょう
[音楽]
早速間近でバトルしていきます次にデッキ作る時なんですけども
まじか図2枚あれば戦えるんだよ4パックかければも戦いますじゃあめっちゃルールも
簡単なんで早速やっていきましょーかい効果あるぞよろしくお願いします
[音楽]
安い
上まずサーバー t
おおーー
これはいきなり音2色房破り武山健タイプ
ちゃんタワー
ベースパーティーを
空がぐう de
ん
キラーピラーなので俺の負けあっはっ
ふぅ
+もうねこれはプラッシーってはい
つまり ok 作ですその母さんホークダウンです
でです
まじかパーン
を勝てば it やっぱ5000以上のマンションダンスのいい
まあ切るわけにはいかないということかそういうことだネッツ
旅
おおおッ買ったやばい俺はやばいね裏じゃんけんでアームスターの場合は
グーチョキパーよりも良いかとして
これ買った場合相手のパワー5000以上の場所はダウンすると思う
有限頭がやられただと良香たかった
俺はまだ諦めてない
いきますうぇっまじかパーティー
6しんぐらー俺が勝てばと3日の混ぜ数苦難からターンを2倍してますちょっと考え
たちが多彩なんだよ
教わって負けたくないねぇパーティー
じゃあ
もう本当のようで純粋の全県の理由
牧神比べタウン
最後としているはお前だめっまじかパーティ
ばあさんやバーンバーンニャー入っ
って
きっと勝つと自分と相手のプラスチックろうあの dj マークの種類かける
power plus センサーこれが dj タイムで勝てば
5声上がれますだからパワーが3000以上になったら勝てるけど3倍せなきゃ隠滅を
出そうですね
いきます
ベイツパーティー
よしよしとビッグ3ワンチャンス気を使います
[音楽]
はいえーと+グラーノバズが1枚を戻します
ま日記ほどしていいですかん
3番してますなまじっかパーティー名せプライ
いくが入っ
ねぇ
パーティーですよねーしましたが
バーン vardia の魂がパワー9000
うわぁ
あんまりつけてあああああうわあブーン
ショッカー
化したあああ
えええあ
やられただろうな濃いですけどもバッハ
んまぁらぁぁ
俺の抹茶
いい勝負だった人勝負だったねこれね
最後の最後までやっぱこーねじゃんけんカードのほかに村木らからだ何があったんです
よソコロね枚数のすっ
読み合いですよね結構
京都ミクさんの僕も初めてやってみたんですけども本当にすぐ覚えて誰でも簡単に
遊べると思います
まじかパーティーの予約開始日が4月の2日でございますよっ
みなさんぜひ予約33で見てください同市なんと4月から地上波兄ね
まじかパーティーがスタートええええええアジアではダメですはいはいら
盛り上がりそうマジでどんなにかといいますと
魔神と魔法使いとして選ばれた少年たちが降り出す超上げアパ4パーティーパートナー
に
here 歳以下 ivan ek あっ here さっきの
[音楽]
voodoo
あってちょ